une production du studio SF
ile le podcast où on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités du pH Quentin avec
moi Doom planque on se politique non
on parle enfin un retour sur les mythers
Américains qui dans les dernières
semaines aux États-Unis élection qui a
eu un résultat complètement inattendu et
on en parle avec le meilleur avec
Frédéric Gagnon qu'on a déjà reçu sur le
podcast qui est la personne quand tu
veux parler de politique quand tu veux
le King le top du top tu t'appelles
Frédéric Gagnon prof à l'IDM il est
directeur de la chair Raoul d'endurance
donc si vraiment un spécialiste de la
politique américaine et la suit
il est allé sur le terrain durant
l'émetteur suivre aller quand il pue de
comment ça se passe là-bas clairement
c'est pas intéressant puis on est aussi
parlé de le retour de Donald Trump
on parle aussi des élections de 2024 qui
approche rapidement aux États-Unis
l'élection qui va être encore une fois
déterminante et
ça peut aller dans toutes les sens ça va
être intéressant à suivre de loin mais
ça va être aussi effrayant l'impression
comme vous allez quand entendre dans le
podcast avec Frédéric seulement donc
c'était vraiment super passionnant je
pense que si vous avez politique
américaine vous intéresse vous allez
triper puis si vous intéresse moins bien
vous allez peut-être parce qu'on on
vulgarise bien aussi les concepts avec
Frédéric fait que c'est facile
une mention spéciale à Frédéric qui est
aussi notre personne ressource à chaque
fois qu'il y a des des enjeux
internationaux on écrit à Frédéric on
demande ce serait qui la bonne personne
à recevoir puis c'est ce qui a donné
plein de bons podcasts là que c'est pas
mal les podcasts lesquels je me fais le
plus parler le CAC 40 on aborde des
enjeux comme ça ben faudrait que
toujours la bonne personne à nous
proposer évidemment les personnes qui
viennent ici sont tout incroyables donc
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par cosy what donc je t'ai parlé de mon
divan oui puis même aux auditeurs je
vous ai parlé de mon divin on connaît on
connaît toutes sur ton divin puis
peut-être que vous avez vu passer
cosy.ca sur votre fille d'Instagram ou
Facebook parce que sont quand même assez
actifs sur les réseaux sociaux mais il y
a une raison à ça c'est parce que c'est
de la bombe absolue moi depuis que j'ai
du vent là même
ma vie a pris un step c'est s'installer
dans un divan confortable pour écouter
un film
[Musique]
tu peux choisir la disposition de ton
divers si tu veux un divan
en ligne droite tu peux avoir des
Ottomans qui est des petites des petits
coussins que tu te promènes pour mettre
tes jambes tu peux avoir la couleur que
tu veux tu peux avoir le modèle que tu
veux ils ont deux modèles il y en a un
plus dur il y en a un plus ferme
devrais-je dire un plus moelleux il
envoie ça dans des boîtes chez vous
t'as pas besoin d'outils pour les monter
je fais juste les monter comme des gros
blocs Lego
ultra confortables Pika venant le temps
de déménager encore de chez nous easy
easy easy tu défais ça puis tu les
ramènes là c'est le temps des fêtes le
temps des fêtes c'est le temps d'offrir
des cadeaux oui aux autres mais à soi
aussi cosy ça fait trop longtemps
de poussière c'est le temps
qui va fêter parfaitement dans ta déco
dans ton salon
tu peux même pas chanter ton salon puis
l'installer pour voir de quoi il y avait
c'est incroyable fait aller au cosy.ca
puis c'est le temps de panier ça moi je
suis infiniment satisfait de mon divan
fait que merci cosy puis cosy let's go
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par menscape menscape c'est les produits
ultime pour l'entretien de votre peau de
votre pilosité
de votre odeur moi depuis que j'ai
découvert ça mais depuis qu'en fait on
collabore avec manscape le shampoing et
revitalisé en deux c'est mon goûtu c'est
mon goûtu je me casse pas la tête
j'utilise ça à chaque fois je me lave
les cheveux ça sent bon ça hydrate les
cheveux le bord des wash est incroyable
avec la même odeur caractéristique
sortie des fois il y a du body wash un
peu plus de shape que tu te laves tu
sors tu es sec et sec
c'est pas sec tu es humide tu es hydraté
avec aussi le petit sprit hydratant
honnêtement c'est une routine qui est
absolument incroyable quand tu fais ça
tu sens bon
j'ai de la misère à mettre en mot à quel
point non mais c'est indescriptif c'est
indescriptible à quel point ça a changé
ma vie il y a pas de mots dans langue
française pour exprimer la beauté
[Musique]
une
belle odeur
si cette suite on n'aurait jamais eu
accès au point
[Musique]
utiliser notre code promo sans filtre
pour 20% de rabais puis le shipping
gratuit sur tous les produits manscape
puis en plus ils vont savoir que c'est
nous qui vous envoie c'est le temps de
le faire faites le grand saut Mendes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça roule merci d'être là fait plaisir
merci de me recevoir notre rencontre
c'est quoi à chaque deux ans biannuel
mais deux fois par année
serait deux fois par heure
la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu mais en
partant c'était c'était avant les
élections américaines de 2020 puis là
avec les méthodes les méthodes qui s'en
venaient qu'on en parle on sortait des
élections au Québec podcasts
tout le monde mentionnait que c'était un
événement historique moi je me suis fait
écrire par du monde en direct parler de
ça sur le Podcast parce que plus
compliqué la politique américaine à
comprendre que les élections québécoises
plus long aussi plus longs comme
processus
dans le fond je voulais qu'on revienne
avec toi là sur avant limiteur ce qu'on
pensait qu'elle allait se passer pour
quelle raison puis ensuite jusqu'à
aujourd'hui parce que même après les
résultats des méthodes il y a plusieurs
autres affaires à la politique
américaine qui sont qui sont présentés
le nez là notamment le retour de celui
dont on ne dira pas le nom
juste pour peut-être pour situer les
gens les méthodes c'est quoi pourquoi ça
existe dans la police américaine bon
c'est des élections qui se déroulent
deux ans après l'élection présidentielle
il y en a tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et ce sont des élections
au Congrès des États-Unis le Congrès
c'est la législature fédérale à
Washington le Capitole finalement il y a
deux chambres au Congrès la Chambre des
Représentants et le Sénat donc tous les
sièges la Chambre des représentants sont
en élection les 435 et 1/3 des sièges du
Sénat au Sénat essentiel je fais que
cette année il y avait 35 élections au
Sénat et les démocrates étaient
majoritaires au sein des deux chambres
du Congrès donc ce qui fait que juste
30% des sièges qui sont en vote pourquoi
qui choisit lesquels sont en voie bah au
fond les les fondateurs Américains
voulaient pas que toutes ces élections
là se déroulent en même temps parce
qu'ils voulaient que des alternances au
pouvoir ce qui permettrait toujours des
espèces de le poids au pouvoir des
autres qui se faisaient lire à une autre
élection bon c'était peut-être pas clair
ce que je viens de dire mais dans le
fond le président se fait lire puis deux
ans après l'élection présidentielle on
tient d'autres élections pour permettre
aux adversaires du président de
reprendre une partie du pouvoir donc
c'est toujours l'idée des poids et
contrepoint on voulait pas qu'elle
concentration des fois entre les mains
d'une seule personne tout le temps ou
entre les mains d'une seule institution
tout le temps puis enfin un peu la même
chose au Congrès tous les sièges la
chambre sont en élection aux deux ans
donc les représentants sont élus pour
des mandats de deux ans mais les
sénateurs sont élus pour des mandats de
6 ans donc ils sont là un peu plus
longtemps puis on renouvelle leur siège
une trentaine d'élections aux deux ans
dans leur cas donc ça crée une espèce de
d'occasion plusieurs occasions à ceux
qui aiment pas les gens pouvoir de
changer les élus donc aux deux ans il y
a des élections avec ça donc là il y
avait des élections au Congrès les
démocrates et majoritaires au sein des
deux chambres du Congrès Biden avait pu
grâce à ça garantir l'adoption de toutes
sortes de projets qui avait à cœur et
l'enjeu c'était pour les démocrates de
garder les deux chambres du Congrès
notamment mais il y avait d'autres
élections aussi dans les États
américains à des postes de gouverneur
qui sont l'équivalent de nos premiers
ministres provinciaux dans le fond donc
des François Legault il y en a 50 aux
États-Unis je me réveille la nuit en
sueur en imaginant dans un monde avec
cette carte
c'est juste 50 bonhommes
qui disent des jokes de mon oncle
donc équivalent de François Lego
donc il y a 50 gouverneurs d'État ils
étaient pas tous en élection cette année
il y en avait une trentaine en élection
il y avait des élections municipales
aussi donc c'est comme si on vous
demandait finalement de voter pour vos
députés fédéraux votre premier ministre
votre mère ou mairesse de la Ville de
Montréal ou donc plusieurs élections en
même temps toutes sur le même le même
selon l'état dans lequel tu trouves là
tu peux voter pour toutes ces personnes
là ou parfois pas d'élection sénatoriale
dans ton état c'est un peu compliqué
c'est un peu compliqué mais plusieurs
élections des milliers d'élections dans
le fond des questions référendaires
aussi sur les bulletins de vote de
certains électeurs selon les états aussi
donc là il y avait des référendums sur
l'avortement dans cinq États américains
des choses comme ça mais au fond le seul
qui était pas en élection c'était Biden
ouais c'est ça
habituellement pour répondre à la
question que tu te poses que tu posais
au début le président se fait planter le
parti du président se fait planter aux
élections mimanda toujours puis il y a
pas d'exception même quand tu sais parce
que là de ce que j'ai compris le taux de
confiance envers Biden était vraiment
bas puis même les présidents qui ont un
taux approuvé le running se mettant on
sait comment je peux la popularité
même quand il y a des présidents qui ont
un taux d'approbation vraiment haut ils
se font quand même planter au métal non
c'est ça c'est une donnée qu'on regarde
donc tu fais bien de le mentionner
est-ce que le président est populaire ou
pas à l'approche des élections mi-mandes
quand le président est pas très
populaire le baiden est à 42%. comme
Obama en 2010 comme Trump en 2018 qui
est 2010 2018 2022 ce sont des élections
comparables des élections mi-mandat 2
ans après l'arrivée d'un président à la
Maison Blanche donc dans la littérature
scientifique là les chercheurs regardent
souvent le taux d'approbation quand on
est autour de 40%, le président mange
une volée c'est presque systématique
Obama avait perdu les démocrates avaient
perdu une soixantaine de sièges au
médecin de 2010 à la Chambre des
Représentants Trump avait perdu son
parti une quarantaine de sièges à la
Chambre des Représentants et là on
disait ben sur la base de nos théories
et de ce qui se passe habituellement
Eden va manger sa voler aussi parce
qu'il était à 40%
quelque chose comme ça mais c'est pas ça
que c'est passé les républicains ont
gagné un peu à la Chambre des
Représentants ils seront majoritaires ce
sera 222 213 222 républicains 213
démocrate à la chambre mais on n'a pas
assisté à une victoire de 60 la
garantielle des républicains cette
élection-là c'est assez contre-intuitif
ceux qui s'y connaissent prédisaient
peut-être des gains de 25 30 sièges pour
les républicains à la Chambre des
Représentants c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé
un peu moins que ce qu'on a vu dans le
passé pour un taux d'approbation égal
exact mais pas à ce point-là puis les
démocrates ont même réussi à garder le
Sénat des États-Unis ça aussi c'est
assez c'est assez particulier parce que
avant les élections c'était 55 ans au
Sénat 50 démocrates 50 républicains mais
les démocrates étaient majoritaires au
Sénat parce que quand tu es quand tu es
au pouvoir à la Maison Blanche ce qui
est le code en ce moment ben c'est le
vice-président ou la vice-président qui
te donne un vote additionnel au Sénat en
cas d'égalité comme ça donc le 51
provenait de Camara Harris la
vice-président et là on sait déjà qu'on
sera au moins à 55 ans à la reprise des
travaux du prochain congrès en mais il
reste une élection au Sénat un deuxième
tour de vote en Géorgie dans la course
qui oppose un show Walker le républicain
je sais pas si vous avez vu sa
candidature durant l'élection c'était un
ancien joueur de football novice en
politique passé trouble
violence conjugale contre l'avortement
mais il a payé pour des avortements pour
ses ex-copines Trump l'appui affronte
train évidemment et là il y a un
deuxième tour de vent le 6 décembre pour
savoir si un show Walker le républicain
gagne cette sénatori cette sénatoriale
là aussi les démocrates gardent le siège
avec Raphaël Raphaël warnaker actuel de
la Géorgie mais si les démocrates
gagnent cette élection-là ils vont être
encore en meilleure position c'est là
qu'il l'était avant les élections
mi-mandat ça aussi c'est assez rare au
Sénat le parti du président
perd un petit peu moitié habituellement
qu'à la Chambre des Représentants et
parfois le parti du président en gang
quelques-uns mais quand même au metteurs
habitu le parti du président mange une
voilée les présidents aiment pas les
méthodes pour cette raison là et le
problème pour eux généralement c'est que
il se retrouve en situation ils doivent
composer avec une majorité du parti
adverse dans une des chambres du Congrès
ou dans les deux chambres du Congrès là
ben va être pogner avec ça parce que la
Chambre des Représentants va être
républicaine mais la majorité
républicaine sera pas aussi importante
qu'elle aurait pu l'aide dans le
contexte puis concrètement c'est quoi
que ça implique qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ça change en dynamique un mettant un
président qui va perdre les deux
chambres c'est quoi qu'est-ce que ça
change dans dans ses pouvoirs puis dans
dans Comment qu'on fonctionne mais le
Congrès des États-Unis c'est la
législature fédérale est super
indépendante de la maison blanche c'est
pas c'est pas un système qui est comme
le nôtre Justin Trudeau et le premier
ministre du Canada mais il y a aussi un
siège à aussi un siège à l'Assemblée à
l'Assemblée en fait au Parlement
d'Ottawa donc il peut voter sur les
projets de loi sur les projets de budget
et quand sont partis est major contraire
c'est assez facile pour le parti du
Premier ministre de on débat un petit
peu mais ce sont nos projets on va aller
de l'avant avec nos projets on va en
discuter mais on a majorité il y a une
forte discipline de partie puis on va un
petit peu vous imposer ce qu'on souhaite
et c'est un système qui est très
différent du système américain parce que
byden n'a pas de siège au Congrès le
Congrès est très indépendant de la
Maison Blanche et il est très puissant
parce qu'il adopte les lois fédérales il
adopte aussi les budgets fédéraux ok
donc il y a pas il y a pas un sou il y a
pas une pièce des contribuables
américains au fédéral qui peut être
dépensé c'est le Congrès n'a pas n'a pas
autoriser ses dépenses là donc là avec
une chambre républicaine ce que ça veut
dire pour Biden c'est que il va demander
des choses au Congrès mais la Chambre
des Représentants républicaines va
souvent refuser d'adopter les budgets
que Bayonne demande pour mettre de
l'avant ses politiques donc ça c'est une
première chose beaucoup de paralysie
beaucoup de blocages et pendant deux ans
Biden va dire par exemple Biden voulait
des investissements fédéraux pour manger
par un taux pour les parents américains
des garderies des garderies pour les
parents américains aussi c'est l'enfer
légal le système des garderies aux
États-Unis c'est pas notre système de
garderie ça coûte cher c'est difficile
d'avoir
les fonds nécessaires pour envoyer deux
trois enfants dans les garderies et donc
Biden souhaitait que le fédéral offre
des subventions aux parents pour
permettre de payer pour les garderies
bon les républicains sont contre ça
parce que estime que c'est du gaspillage
de fonds publics si vous voulez des
garderies ben ayez la job qu'il faut
pour les pays c'est un peu ça l'idée
républicaine je caricature mais c'est un
peu ça et Biden voulait des
investissements additionnels en matière
de santé les médicaments coûtent
extrêmement cher aux États-Unis donc des
investissements fédéraux pour aider les
Américains américains à se payer
médicament dont ils ont besoin des
investissements
sociaux comme ça et là évidemment les
républicains vont refuser d'aller de
l'avant avec des projets comme ceux-là
des investissements en matière
d'environnement aussi c'est un autre
exemple durant les deux premières années
de sa présidence Biden et les majorités
démocrates au Congrès ont garantit
l'adoption de plusieurs projets visant
des investissements dans les
infrastructures mais des investissements
verts c'est-à-dire les bâtiments
gouvernementaux on va les réparer mais
on va s'assurer que sur un plan
énergétique qui sont eco friendly on va
les isoler davantage pour réduire
l'empreinte énergétique environnementale
des États-Unis les démarches les
républicains évidemment Trump au premier
chef se dit souvent climato-sceptique on
n'a pas besoin d'être ça c'est du
gaspillage de fonds publics donc pendant
les deux prochaines années ça va être
plus difficile pour Biden d'aller de
l'avant avec ses projets et l'autre
affaire c'est que le Congrès est très
puissant parce qu'il va pouvoir
banquette sur les politiques
présidentielles donc au Congrès il y a
des commissions permanentes sur toutes
sortes de questions la justice
l'éducation la politique étrangère les
budgets tout ça et quand un parti
majoritaire dans une chambre du Congrès
là les républicains vont l'être à la
Chambre des Représentants il se retrouve
à diriger ces diverses commissions
permanentes et ils sont majoritaires
aussi au sein de ces diverses
commissions là les commissions un
pouvoir d'enquête sur les politiques
présidentielles donc les républicains
ont déjà promis qui veulent tenir toutes
sortes d'enquêtes sur des politiques de
Biden pour le mettre dans l'embarras
pour le faire mal par paraître pour
l'obliger à envoyer des membres de son
administration témoigner à la Chambre
des représentants pour expliquer ce qui
s'est passé sur toutes sortes de
questions on veut faire des enquêtes les
républicains pas moi les républicains
veulent faire des enquêtes sur le
retrait de l'Afghanistan sur la gestion
de la pandémie par Biden qui a pas été
un grand succès non plus contrairement à
ce que Biden avait promis au départ ce
Hunter Biden vous le connaissez le fils
de Joe Biden les républicains sont
convaincus que lorsque Joe Biden était
vice-président Obama son fils en
turbidden a profité de ça pour avoir
accès à des gens importants à
l'international en Ukraine en Chine et
que ça a été bénéfique assez à ses
affaires économiques personnelles donc
une espèce de conflit d'intérêt ici lui
fait quoi
ben il y a eu des gros gros problèmes de
consommation de drogue il y a eu des
gros gros problèmes personnels mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a fait un homme
d'affaires c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
des affaires à l'international et tout
ça qui a siéger sur des conseils
d'administration de compagnie de
compagnie de toutes sortes qui a été
payé pour ses postes-là pour ces
services et les républicains sont sont
assez convaincus vont faire des enquêtes
là-dessus que on te Biden a eu cette
chance là ces chances-là souvent parce
qu'on son père était connu son père
était vice-président son père lui a
donné des accès auxquels il n'aurait pas
eu droit autrement donc et au fond ce
qu'on veut c'est
c'est vraiment faire mal paraître Biden
faire perdre du temps à byden ne pas
aller de l'avant avec les projets de loi
les projets de budget que Biden soit
très en attendant la prochaine élection
qui essaie de 2024 c'est ce qui est fou
on est déjà en élection en 2024 on avait
même pas tous les résultats de 2022 puis
on était déjà en campagne électorale en
vue 2024 les républicains ils veulent
ils veulent que Biden perdre des plumes
là il est à 42% d'appui au pays dans les
républicains veulent le faire mal
paraître pour qu'ils baissent encore
dans l'opinion dans le pignon public
qu'est-ce qui explique que tu parlais de
la de la gestion de la pandémie que
possible bien été finalement au
contraire de ce que Biden promettait
qu'est-ce qui explique le taux de 42%
comme ça d'approbation pour la les deux
premières années de la présidence de
Biden justement ça a été vu aux
États-Unis
nous autres on voit ça mais j'imagine
que c'est ça c'est juste comme dans le
paraître des mails sur Internet là mais
qu'est-ce qui explique ça non mais juste
pour rebondir la souillé fatigué c'est
clair
je l'ai regardé c'est pas de je suis pas
amoureux de Biden tous les présidents
ont cette job là à faire c'est une job
qui est pas facile c'est il faisait
campagne pour les médecins il était en
Pennsylvanie puis essayer de aider les
candidats candidats démocrates dans les
états clés de l'élection les résultats
tu as même pas encore connu puis lui il
partait en Europe pour des réunions
internationales décalage horaire
évidemment qui s'endort dans des
réunions moi je vais en conférence des
fois à Paris je m'endors aussi j'ai pas
son âge mais c'est quasiment on va
quasiment essayer de le comme quelqu'un
qui est en perte de facultés
en perte de ton ennemi ou juste
dans un centre de soins donc durée là
[Rires]
mais mais il a rendu il a rendu ses
rapports médicaux publics si ça vaut ce
que ça vaut tu peux bon peut-être qu'ils
reprennent mandat un deuxième avis pour
un deuxième médecin dirait mais ça va
pas si bien que ça mais les rapports
médicaux sont corrects pour un gars de
son âge tu sais mais c'est sûr qu'il y a
plus il y a plus l'énergie dans le temps
et puis il y a bien il y a pas mal de
démocrates qui disent ils devraient
laisser sa place pour la suite des
choses un mandat c'est assez parce que
là peut-être que ça va bien mais à la
fin de son deuxième mandat il y aurait
quoi 86 ans c'est une bonne différence
en 80
il y en a d'autres mais là c'est le
problème c'est pour Biden c'est quand on
le voit maintenant on peut pas
dissimuler ça aussi facilement que dans
le temps avec les médias sociaux on le
disait tantôt les clips les mimes les
tout le monde a une caméra dans sa poche
puis on peut on peut filmer Biden qui
déboule un escalier déjà vu chuter dans
un escalier donc puis là ça va mais à 86
ans
je sais pas je sais pas à quoi ça
ressemble parce que déjà à 74 ans il y a
6 ans Biden avait plus d'énergie quand
on a 80 puis là il y a eu un sondage je
réponds pas tout à l'heure mais
il y a eu un sondage récent qui était
intéressant ça vaut ce que ça vaut les
sondages il y a eu des erreurs aussi
dans les sondages en 2022 on prend en
parler mais qui disait que il y a une
majorité de démocrates
américaines il y a une majorité aussi
démocrate qui estime que Biden devrait
laisser sa place après un mandat donc
c'est pas juste les adversaires de Biden
qui disent il sera plus capable bientôt
il y a aussi des gens dans le parti qui
disent bon Biden nous a rendu service il
y a battu Trump en 2020 c'était lui que
ça prenait pour battre un par 2020 salut
que ça prenait on en avait parlé la
dernière fois il y avait réussi à aller
chercher la coalition nécessaire pour
gagner la présidentielle
il nous a rendu service mais plusieurs
démocrates le voient un petit peu comme
un président de transition 4 ans puis
après ça on passe à autre chose parce
que de la relève du côté démocrate
mais on reviendra sur les élections 2022
mais ça serait quand même surprenant qui
se représente non
c'est vraiment la question un million de
dollars moi je te dirais que s'il y
avait perdu si les démocrates c'était
fait plantes aux élections 2022 là je
pense que dans le parti là il y a
beaucoup de démocrates qui aurait dit ok
là c'est pas la solution pour la suite
des choses mais Biden et un des gagnants
des élections 2022 c'est un des
présidents les plus impopulaires de
l'histoire depuis qu'on tient des
sondages là-dessus un des présidents les
plus impopulaires à perdre si peu aux
élections de mi-mandat c'est un peu
comme quand les Canadiens étaient
presque dans le cas puis on fait la
finale la Coupe du Monde c'est la moins
bonne équipe de l'histoire à faire la
finale c'était très étonnant et 2022
pour moi c'est un peu ça avec Biden dit
quoi
mais c'est ça qui a dit d'ailleurs au
lendemain desiteuses ce qui a dit c'est
ben voyez il y a vraiment un appétit
pour ce que j'ai proposé qu'est-ce que
j'ai proposé
des investissements dans les
infrastructures de ramener de bons
emplois aux États-Unis tout ça mais ce
que j'ai promis aussi c'est un retour à
la modération
moins de cris moins chicane moins de
base politique moins d'attaques
personnelles les gens sont années de ça
si tu regardes 2022 bah il y a beaucoup
de d'observateurs d'observatrices qui
qui voit ça dans les résultats 2020
mais les analystes qu'est-ce qui
explique cette pas cette victoire
démocrate mais
pratiquement cette victoire démocratique
le succès des démocrates à ce point là
aux élections malgré leur président et
populaire malgré leur président
populaire mais les candidatures
républicaines certaines d'entre elles
étaient complètement débile que je vais
utiliser ce mot-là
aussi qui disent mais on avait des
candidatures loufoques qui ont contribué
à ce qu'on observe là aux metteurs de
ça c'est documenté si vous allez sur le
site du Washington Post New York Times
il y en a plein five terrier tout ça il
y a plein de sites où on nous montre qui
des candidats républicains étaient
étaient dans le moule de Trump et qui
disait notamment qu'il y a eu un grand
vol électoral à l'élection 2020 donc le
Big Lay le grand mensonge on nous a volé
l'élection fraude majeur des candidats
endossés par Trump aussi imagine donc
des élections de nairer c'est des gens
qui disent on croit pas aux résultats
2020 on s'est fait avoir alors que ça a
jamais été prouvé s'il y a eu des
enquêtes il y a eu des recontages et
même des républicains qui ont fait ces
enquêtes-là c'est recontage là et on n'a
pas prouvé que Alex qui a eu fraude
électoral majeur en 2020 surprise
surprise mais Trump continue à dire je
suis une victime je me suis fait voler
et en 2022 il y avait des centaines de
candidats républicains qui étaient qui
étaient qui étaient faits dans qui était
exactement ça donc il y en a plusieurs
qui ont gagné on estime que à la Chambre
des représentants sur les 222
républicains qui aura la chambre on
estime qu'il y en a plus de 150 qui sont
des élections de nirus comme ça les
Trump est dur vous allez entendre les
arguments de trempe à la Chambre des
Représentants là c'est pour ça que je
dis qu'il va y avoir des enquêtes sur
Biden ça va être l'enfer mais il y a
beaucoup de candidatures Trump qui sont
plantés aussi et des candidatures qui
étaient très très importantes pour le
parti républicain cette année au Sénat
il y a plusieurs personnes observateurs
qui disent au fond les républicains ont
pas repris la majorité parce que les
candidatures Trump a des élections clés
sont faits planter en Pennsylvanie tu
avais dans des élections qui étaient
importantes
je sais pas si ça vaut la peine d'entrer
dans les détails et les sur les
candidatures et tout ça mais en pleine
Sylvanie on a vu ça on a vu ça bon en
Géorgie je l'ai mentionné tantôt on
verra ce qui se passe le 6 décembre et
tout ça
et aussi à des postes de gouverneur donc
l'équivalent des François Legault dont
je parlais tantôt il y en a une qui
mérite dans le nom mérite d'être
mentionné puis ceux qui regardent le
podcast peuvent aller voir de quoi ça a
l'air mais ça s'appelle carry Lake était
candidat était candidate au poste de
gouverneur en Arizona puis c'est pas moi
qui le dit il y a des gens qui ont dit
karylex est dans notre chambre
les médias nous vendent des fake news la
pandémie ça a été exagérée ça donnait
rien de porter le masque il y a eu un
vol majeur à l'élection 2020 et tout ça
mais à pas gagner a perdu a perdu puis
trempe la voyait comme ça coulisseur en
vue de 2024 on verra si il décide de
choisir une perdante parce qu'il n'aime
pas les perdant habituellement mais il y
a eu vraiment oui
tantôt quand on parlera 2024 mais
candidat comme ça qui ont perdu leurs
élections ça explique en partie pourquoi
les républicains ont pas on peut aussi
bien fait qu'on aurait pu qu'on aurait
pu le croire fait
ceux qui s'enlignent dans la en fait ça
en dit quand même sur la place que
Trump occupe dans le paysage républicain
dans le sens où là c'est pu si clair que
ça que sa façon de faire de la politique
et celle adoptée par les électeurs dans
le fond j'écoutais ce matin de délits en
fait un épisode justement un genre de
post mortem sur limiteur puis un des
analystes disaient ça justement le
trumpisme hors de Trump fonctionne pas
aussi bien qu'on a recrute la plupart
justement de ces politiciens-là la
plupart ont on disait voici une
technique clairement fonctionne je vois
je vois la copier je vais l'adopter mais
finalement c'est c'est plus la personne
que c'est vraiment la personne qui est
plus que ces méthodes ouais je pense que
oui c'est la personne de Trump qui
attire encore beaucoup et qui plaît
encore beaucoup donc un espèce de
il y a une espèce de déconnexion en ce
moment entre le parti républicain les
élus républicains des candidatures Trump
est gagné que ça marche pas
et Trump et c'est partisans parce que ça
c'est assez particulier mais
il y a perdu bon les gens disent des
grands perdants des élections 2022 les
candidatures qu'avant dossé plusieurs se
sont plantés et tout ça mais il y a
encore beaucoup de gens qui tripent sur
lui et puis on est allés sur le terrain
avant les élections de 2022 comme on
fait tout le temps on va sur le terrain
chaque fois qu'il y a des élections aux
États-Unis cette année on est allé une
semaine du 23-29 octobre puis on a
décidé d'aller dans le Midwest américain
là c'est vraiment l'épicentre des
élections américaines depuis 2016 c'est
l'autre Trump avait gagné c'est là où
bidon a repris la maison blanche puis en
2022 il y avait plusieurs élections clés
dans ces états-là donc on le fait entre
autres la Pennsylvanie le Michigan le
West cantine l'Ohio on rentre on rentre
dans les bureaux dans les bureaux de
campagne électorales démocrate on leur
demande comment ça se passe quels sont
les enjeux qu'est-ce qui intéresse les
électeurs tout ça quels sont vos quelles
sont vos craints quels sont pensez-vous
que vous allez gagner moins il faut
aussi avec les
puis c'est intéressant parce que dans
ces bureaux là tu as des directeurs de
campagne électorales je te dis
conseillers de campagne électorales des
candidats républicains mais tu as aussi
beaucoup de bénévoles tu rencontres des
électeurs et tout ça et tu vois qu'auras
des pâquerettes les gens du côté
républicain très encore beaucoup sur
Trump si on est entré dans les bureaux
républicains il y a encore la phase de
Trump sur les murs la photo de Trump est
sur les murs puissant encore c'est un
peu comme le crucifix dans nos maisons
des années 50 la phase de Trump est
encore là puis on l'a décroche pas des
murs
donc oui je pense que je serais d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit dans le délit il y
a beaucoup de candidats républicains qui
essaient de se la jouer comme Trump que
cette faire des campagnes comme comme
lui mais ça marche pas autant que ce
qu'il fait lui les gosses qui disaient
c'est des Trump diet l'autisme
mais c'est ça absolument
aussi c'est le non Trump est tellement
connu et tellement et la notoriété c'est
devenu important politique ici aussi on
le voit là-dessus que je parlerai pas
trop de politique québécoises avec
canadiennes mais les parties se tournent
souvent vers des gens connus maintenant
c'est des anciens journalistes des
vedettes sportives tout ça aux
États-Unis on est beaucoup là-dedans
c'est Trump il y a pas il y a pas un an
plus connu que Trump aux États-Unis il y
a Clinton il y en a quelques-uns au
Bahamas c'est très connu mais Trump
c'est extrêmement connu donc des
tremplettes n'ont pas le nom de Trump en
partant donc ils partent un petit peu
plus loin qui doivent se faire connaître
ça marche pas autant c'est pas aussi
facile c'est pas donc c'est ça et mes 30
reste encore super populaire dans les
sondages aussi en vue de l'élection 2024
c'est là il y a des sondages tu as
encore tôt mais il y a des sondages en
vue des primaires républicaines la
course à HF free républicaine pour la
générale de 2024 est encore premier dans
les sondages puis ça a été quoi son sa
présence son implication dans les
méthodes que tu es complètement absent
puis on peut imaginer que peut-être s'il
y avait été plus vocale ou du moins dans
le paysage
plus du parti républicain que ça aurait
changé les résultats il y a été il a été
très présent en fait il était très
présent
donc à participer à plusieurs
rassemblements électoraux pour appuyer
en fait des candidats qu'il avait
endossé personnellement donc c'est rendu
en noyau pour appuyer j'ai des vents qui
était une élection Sénat il s'est rendu
à Pennsylvanie pour aider mes méthodes
et dogmastria donc des candidats
puis
je te jure si s'il y avait pas été là il
y aurait pas eu autant de monde assez
rassemblements là c'est ça un peu le
problème le problème du parti
républicain en ce moment c'est que là il
voit qu'avec Trump ils perdent des
élections une après l'autre c'est 2016
il y a gagné mais il y a eu moins de
vote que Clinton il a gagné quand même
chapeau mais en 2018 on est Trump s'est
fait planter 2020 mais il a perdu
l'élection lui dit que il dit non mais
il a perdu 2022 il a perdu aussi puis
même quand il y a essayé de se prendre
pour un dictateur il aura été son coup
d'État et si janvier 2021 donc il part
tout le temps
donc les républicains disent c'est
peut-être pas la solution pour 2024 mais
en même temps les partisans Trump sont
tellement convaincus que le parti
républicain peut pas se passer de cet
électoral les candidats au médecin de
plusieurs d'entre eux entraient étaient
très contents que Trump Vienne dans leur
état parce que ça attire les foules puis
les gens restaient extrêmement motivés à
l'idée de suivre 30 pour la suite des
choses
l'autre point je pense que qui est
intéressant que j'entendais c'était les
élections sur lesquelles
l'avortement est un enjeu ouais qui ont
réagi vraiment différemment que d'autres
années dans le passé peux-tu en parler
un peu de ça mais c'est ça c'est un
autre c'est un autre enjeu dont on doit
parler pour comprendre les résultats de
sur le terrain quand on posait la
question aux gens c'est quoi l'enjeu là
qui vous préoccupe en ce moment ce qu'on
voyait c'est que plusieurs personnes
disaient c'est l'économie c'est
l'inflation surtout dans le Midwest
c'est des villes en lambeau des
quartiers abandonnés à 60% puis pas
juste à des trois là tu te promènes tu
vois des bâtiments placardés un peu
partout c'est une région
où il y a beaucoup de détresse
économiques donc c'est sûr que ce qu'on
entendait là c'est c'est l'économie qui
est importante l'inflation veut régler
ses problèmes là et il y a beaucoup de
sondages qui montraient que l'inflation
et l'économie était les enjeux les plus
importants pour 50% des électeurs 55 %
des électeurs et tout ça l'avortement
était là c'est un enjeu important mais
mais pas tant que ça dans les sondages
avant les élections ce qu'on a vu au
lendemain des élections c'est qu'en fait
l'avortement a été beaucoup plus
important que les sondages le disaient
l'inflation et l'économie un petit peu
moins importante l'inflation et
l'économie c'est un enjeu qui
avantageait les républicains parce que
il y a plusieurs électeurs qui disaient
c'est la faute de baiden ce qui se passe
en détail le gouverneur de l'État
en veulent aller de l'avant avec des
mesures comme ça donc
s'inquiète bien des gens surtout du côté
démocrate mais ça inquiète bien des gens
et ce qu'on constate dans les sondages
aux sorties des urnes aux élections 2022
des sondages qu'on mène au bureau de
vote les lecteur vote on dit attends je
veux savoir pourquoi te voter qu'est-ce
qui t'intéressait tout ça les sondages
aux sorties des autres montrent que
l'avortement a fait a été beaucoup plus
important à ces élections là que ce
qu'on avait prévu donc ça c'est sûr que
ça aidait les démocrates qui ont réussi
grâce à
cet enjeu là à faire à faire sortir le
vote dans plusieurs États où il y avait
des élections clés là pour conserver des
postes de sénateurs pose de gouverneur
et tout ça donc l'avortement ça a été ça
a été super important dans d'autres
États c'est plutôt l'inflation et
l'économique qui a été déterminante là
les républicains ont été plus avantagés
dans ce cas-là il y a un argument qu'on
a entendu aussi beaucoup du côté
démocrate c'était
que le parti républicain mettait en
doute
été un danger pour les fondements même
de la démocratie est-ce que premièrement
est-ce que c'est une critique qui qui
valide est-ce que vraiment mettons c'est
un parti qui ce qui va jusqu'à là puis
est-ce que tu penses que ça va jouer
dans la balance des électeurs ça te fait
a été assez important comme argument
pour convaincre des gens de de pauvreté
pour le ce parti-là est-ce que est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est un enjeu
est-ce que c'est un enjeu important oui
on le voyait sur le terrain les gens
sont très inquiets de l'avenir de la
démocratie américaine
mais les démocrates et les républicains
sont pas équipés pour les mêmes raisons
c'est ça qui est drôle les républicains
les démocrates nous disent les membres
des deux parties les électeurs des deux
parties nous disent je m'inquiète pour
la démocratie américaine ah ouais
pourquoi les démocratise
janvier 2021
on sait pas reparler de ça mais moi
j'étais à la maison je capote
mais ouais je me rappelle avoir capoté
aussi
donc les démocrates nous disaient ça ça
nous a fait peur on pense que ça peut
arriver encore à l'avenir parce que si
Trump se présente en 2024 puis encore
une élection serrée comme en 2020
c'est pas qu'il va concéder là et là le
problème c'est que je le disais tantôt
en 2022 même si plusieurs de ses
candidats Trump ont perdu il y en a
beaucoup qui sont faits et lire à des
postes clés dans les États américains
disons
mais en tout cas dans les États
américains il y a un poste très
important qui s'appelle le poste de
secrétaire d'État c'est pas comme le
secrétaire d'État au fédéral qui est
responsables à diplomatie américaine
mais dans les états tu as un poste qui
s'appelle secrétaire d'État et au fond
c'est le responsable des élections le
responsable notamment de la
certification des résultats des
élections dans les temps en question
lorsque des élections fédérales
américaines donc ce que ça veut dire
c'est quand une élection présidentielle
on vote dans les états les États sont
responsables de gérer les élections sur
leur territoire ayant un secrétaire
d'État qui dit ok on a voté ici je
certifie que les résultats sont valides
et on peut poursuivre le processus qui
mènera au couronnement du président au
Congrès des États-Unis simplifie mais en
janvier de l'année qui suit l'élection
présidentielle le 6 janvier 2021 quand
il y a eu la tentative de coup d'état on
était rendu là à la certification des
résultats au Congrès résultat qui
provenaient les différents états
américains donc les pour en revenir à ce
que je disais craigne pour la démocratie
américaine parce qu'il voyait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de candidats au poste de
secrétaire d'État dans divers états
américains qui croient comme Trump qui a
eu une fraude électorale majeure en 2020
OK et qui s'ils avaient été en poste à
ce moment-là aurait dit je ne certifie
pas
ses résultats je suis en désaccord avec
ce qui se passe et il va falloir
attendre parce que nous on a encore des
enquêtes à faire évidemment ça ralentit
le processus électoral tu peux te
retrouver avec une crise
constitutionnelle et tu peux te
retrouver avec un candidat une élection
qui s'appuie sur ce que c'est secrétaire
d'états disent pour ne pas reconnaître
le résultat de l'élection américaine
donc les démocrates nous disent on
craint ça on craint là on crée un moment
semblable aussi janvier 2021 mais là on
a des élus au Congrès qui refusent de
certifier les résultats de l'élection ok
tu en as des secrétaires d'État dans
divers états américains qui disent nous
non plus on n'est pas d'accord avec ce
qui s'est passé puis là tu as un Trump
qui dit
ben je conseille pas puis tu as des gros
armés d'extrême droite qui qui vont acte
violent ici et là qui vise des
institutions politiques donc c'est une
crainte qui est
fondée moi je mange je pense que
malheureusement je pense que je pense
que c'est le genre de situation qui peut
se produire à l'avenir d'ailleurs j'ai
écrit contexte dans la presse juste
avant les élections où je disais à la
démocratie américaine est à l'agonie en
ce moment l'occasion de
les électeurs en 2022 ont l'occasion de
laisser la démocratie aller dans DALO ou
de ou de ou de redresser un petit peu la
situation là il y a eu en 2022 des
défaites importantes de Trump piste de
gens qui qui nient encore les résultats
de 2020 donc je pense qu'on a un petit
peu sauvé la mise mais encore ce
risque-là et pour en revenir aux
républicains eux aussi pensent que des
menaces à la démocratie parce que disent
qu'il y a des fraudes électorales
majeurs maintenant chaque fois que les
élections donc l'enjeu est important
mais c'est comme si ça s'annulait un
petit peu parce que les démocrates
votent sur cette question là en disant
je veux pas d'autres c'est janvier 2021
les républicains votent sur cette photo
je veux pas d'autres vols je veux que
les secrétaires d'État les élus du
Congrès soit des gens qui ne
reconnaîtront pas les résultats de
l'élection si on juge qu'il y a eu
fraude c'est complètement on était quand
on était sur le terrain un moment donné
on entre dans un bureau de un bureau de
campagne électorale républicain d'un
côté en banlieue de Milwaukee Canson
puis là on rencontre un républicain
convaincu qui nous parle pendant une
heure je te jure dans le détail des
fraudes électorales majeurs de 2020 ouh
il est convaincu de son affaire
c'est complètement c'est la théorie du
complot le pays il y a rien à faire il a
regardé beaucoup de vidéos YouTube
beaucoup de vidéos YouTube
que ça s'est produit malgré les enquêtes
malgré même s'il y a des républicains
qui ont qui sont mis là-dedans et qui
ont dit ben non malheureusement puis ce
qui nous explique c'est que
au fond les fraudes électorales majeurs
se produisent de plus en plus en raison
du vote par correspondance et du vote
par la pousse ce qui nous explique c'est
que
disons que tu es un électeur vous êtes
des électeurs américains
vous pouvez faire une demande sur
internet
pour recevoir un bulletin de vote que
vous remplirez que vous enverrez par la
poste pour voter par la poste pour voter
par correspondance ce sont surtout les
démocrates qui votent par correspondance
c'est ce qu'on a vu c'est un phénomène
qui a été particulièrement
ça a été particulièrement cas durant la
pandémie de covid 19 ou les démocrates
avaient plus peur du virus que les
républicains en plus voté par la poste
et tout ça mais encore l'an 2022 surtout
des démocrates qui votent par la poste
donc le républicain nous dit vous êtes
des électeurs américains vous pouvez
très bien commander faire une demande
sur internet pour recevoir trois quatre
bulletins de vote puis lorsque vous
faites c'est que vous regardez dans les
listes électorales vous trouvez les noms
et les adresses des lecteurs qui ont pas
voté depuis quelques cycles électoraux
et vous prenez une chance en utilisant
l'identité de cette personne là et en
votant en son nom mais trois quatre fois
comme ça
et donc ce qui nous disait c'est qu'il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui ont fait
ça apparemment ça n'a pas été prouvé
mais en 2020 que ça va se produire
encore en 2022 c'était avant l'élection
j'ai pas reparlé je sais pas si mais
c'est ça
mais c'est ça leur crainte et ça a pas
été prouvé enfin il y a une personne qui
s'est fait il y a une personne qui a été
arrêtée je me souviens pas c'est dans
quel état mais il y a eu un cas de
fraude comme ça quelqu'un qui le fait ça
ok c'est un républicain trumpiste qui
voulait prouver que ça se faisait mais
il s'est fait pogné
très facile comme méthode ils ont passé
à ça mais oui effectivement
sauf que ce qu'il nous disait lui c'est
que il faudrait que l'État
après l'élection
avant qu'on certifie les résultats il
faudrait que l'État remonte jusqu'aux
électeurs pour s'assurer que les votes
par correspondance que l'État reçu ne
sont pas frauduleux mais t'imagines
faire du River c'est une génération
refaire l'élection à l'envers pour
remonter jusqu'aux électeurs qui ont
voté par la poste c'est vraiment
il y a toujours des cas des cas mais ça
reste mineur c'est ça c'est un enjeu
comme
Total assez pour faire gagner des
élections on le saurait mais c'est comme
c'est comme tout le temps les théories
du complot là c'est quand même il y a
trop de monde impliqués pour qu'on le
sache pas il y a tout le monde impliqué
pour que ça sorte pas exact puis mais
c'est fou là écoute il était convaincu
je vais dire pas un con le gars
quelqu'un qui lit énormément visiblement
quelqu'un il nous parlait de ça dans le
détail mais sabre à des sources
d'informations
problématique mais écoute ça c'est le
récit c'est son récit d'une heure quand
nous on était là donc ça ce sont des
choses qui disent aux électeurs qui
pensent au bureau là tout le temps puis
on a vu ça en banlieue de de milwa qui
on a vu ça en banlieue des trois on a vu
ça si on entend ça dans plusieurs
bureaux républicains donc les démocrates
sont inquiets parce que c'est un mot du
problème en démocratie quand tu gagnes
ces beaux mais tu perds tu acceptes pas
des faits
puis tu disais qu'il y a plusieurs ont
été vaincus mais aussi je pense tu me
dis 150 à peu près personne qui ont été
à la Chambre des Représentants
ce qui est un peu paradoxal parce qu'ils
sont quand même dans ce système là puis
quand ils sont élus ça fait la race
mais ça peut quand même inquiétant pour
2024 qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer à
cette sélection-là ça reste inquiétant
ça reste inquiétant
c'est une société qui reste super
divisée les élections présidentielles
récentes ont été quand même serrées
2016-2020 on peut s'attendre à ce que ce
soit serré encore en 2024 j'ai encore là
mais si vous regardez les sondages les
hypothèses en ce moment Biden contre
Biden contre quelqu'un d'autre
c'est super serré encore c'est 42% 43%.
on reste là dedans et ça risque d'être
ça va être ça risque d'être très serré
en 2024 ça risque de se jouer de se
jouer dans quelques états trois quatre
étant encore une fois et les marges de
victoire risque d'être dans ces trois
catégories le 20.000 25000 votes 70000
va puis là on compte pendant des jours
un peu comme ce qui se passait 2022 on a
même pas encore tous les résultats parce
que dans les états où ça compte c'est
toujours extrêmement serré donc et si
c'est serré ben tu as un risque de
contestation quand c'est clair là tu
peux pas dire ah il y a eu fraude c'est
un peu ce que tu disais tantôt si tu
perds
majeur on va dire va te coucher là tu as
perdu même tu sais mais si tu perds
c'est un but qui était louche mais pas
19 là exactement
vous allez avoir encore 20 secondes je
veux qu'on ait une autre période de
prolongation moi je veux continuer
les républicains
j'imagine que
la course à la chefferie républicaine va
être aussi un téléramment à suivre parce
que là le Trump a annoncé sa
participation dans le fond son retour
il y a de retour sur Twitter aussi
depuis le thé qu'on veut de masque de
Twitter exact
il y a dessus vraiment des adversaires
assez forts
lui moi ce que de ce que j'entendais
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de républicains
qui disent peut-être que suite aux trois
défaites consécutives de Trump peut-être
que c'est lui la solution qui semble
quand même
radical de droite mais peut-être un
petit peu plus modéré que Trump c'est
quoi c'est comment en ligne ça ok si on
regarde les sondages en ce moment il est
super tôt mais
en tout cas si on regarde les sondages
en ce moment Trump est encore le favori
du côté républicain pour 2024 pour la
course à la chefferie dans son parti là
les primaires qu'on appelle il reste
favoris il y a à peu près il y a à peu
près à 50% d'appui dans le parti
parmi les électeurs qui se prononcent de
synthèse de sentir se monter dans les
sondages après les méthodes de 2022
parce que lui a gagné son élection poste
de gouverneur en Floride de façon là
évidente il y a planté son adversaire
démocrate une marge de 20 points je
pense qu'il y a eu 60% du vote 40% pour
le démocrate Trump en 2020 avait gagné
je pense 51% du vote en Floride
donc Trump a moins bien fait en Floride
en 2020 que descente en Floride en 2022
c'est une grosse victoire
donc de santé c'est évidemment comme je
suis là
à gauche a décidé de s'installer en
Floride Trump a une espèce d'histoire
d'amour avec la Floride en ce moment
plate de synthèse lui dit mais moi je
suis plus hâte que toi dans ton état
même donc ça doit être bon pour un égo
maniaque comme comme Trump
il l'a attaqué sur les médias sociaux
puis mais bon quand même donc de santé
ça monter dans les sondages un petit peu
mais il est encore deuxième il y a pas
encore annoncé qui se lançait
officiellement peut-être que quand il va
se lancer officiellement
peut-être qu'il va continuer à monter
dans les sondages peut-être qu'il va
dépasser 30 mais de santé c'est pas une
figure aussi connue que Trump
premièrement donc il va devoir se faire
connaître à l'extérieur de la Floride et
connu et quand même connu au pays mais
pas comme Trump pour des raisons que
j'évoquais tantôt la notoriété de Trump
est incomparable dans ce pays-là
c'est vraiment un républicain d'extrême
droite que des positions semblables à
Trump qui a appuyé trempe dans le passé
d'ailleurs si vous si vous voulez
regarder une publicité assez dramatique
assez drôle de dessiner lors d'un cycle
électoral précédent c'était 2016 Trump
était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de santé s'était candidat
à l'élection poste de gouverneur en
Floride puis il y a une pub de descentis
où on le voit avec des pancartes de
trempe moi je suis un trumpiste là il y
a un bébé dans je pensais son enfant
probablement
il joue au bloc on construit un mur de
bloc comme Trump veut construire un mur
à la française
évidemment 30 va ressortir cette pub là
plus tard en disant hey de synthèse
donc un peu le même genre de républicain
très conservateur sur l'immigration très
conservateur sur les les impôts sur la
pandémie c'est de synthétis a été un des
premiers à dire
c'est fioul le masque là on veut rien
savoir de ça que les mesures de
confinement on veut rien savoir de
s'enfler dans vos continuer à vivre
librement tout ça sa vision de
l'élection de 2020 c'est quoi lui
je pense je me souviens pas exactement
mais il me semble il me semble qu'il
était qui faisait partie des élections
de Nyers à ce moment là aussi
me semble j'avoue que j'ai pas regardé
ça spécifiquement
mais c'est un candidat extrêmement
conservateur
sauf que moi je l'ai vu en débat cette
année parce qu'il y avait des débats
pour la course au poste de gouverneur en
Floride j'ai regardé son débat contre le
démocrates Charlie Christ et c'était
super intéressant de regarder le débat
parce qu'il est pas si bon que ça en
débat je pense que vous me voyez venir
mais pas si bon que ça débat quand
Charlie se démocrate l'attaquant un
petit peu et grimaçait à repaire à
l'aise il y avait pas ça qui est le
meilleur pour démolir
et là ben de santé c'est un peu la
saveur du moi il y a gagné facilement il
doit être bon mais les gens connaissent
pas encore beaucoup et je pense qu'en
débat notamment Trump pourrait le
démolir un peu comme il a fait avec les
autres en 2016 et oui en 2016 justement
c'est tellement parti de loin puis il
est tellement bon justement pour manier
l'image les médias c'est exactement ce
qui projette puis comment jouer avec ça
que là en partant de vraiment moins le
moins en 2024
facilement remporter mais je sais pas si
il va gagner mais il favori c'est clair
YouTube quelqu'un d'autre de synthèse
sinon il y a le vice-président l'ancien
vice-président Mike pence qui lui a fait
une sortie dernièrement en disant que
Trump avait mis sa vie en danger là deux
ans trop tard je te dirai c'est un peu
moi je leur ai dit 7 janvier 2021 son
pur mais ils craignait peut-être pour sa
sécurité même à ce moment-là mais au
fond si les gens excuse-moi j'étais
la mouche qui se fait poser sur ses
cheveux qui était resté là pendant si
vous vous rappelez de ça je pense qu'il
veut la choisir comme policier
dans le béton
ça fait pas pendant toute parce que Mike
Pen c'est est probablement
c'est tellement
chorégraphié c'est tellement il y a
aucune aucune improvisation
[Rires]
mais Mike Pen c'est ça beaucoup beaucoup
disent de lui qu'il est très très
opportuniste mais
de façon péjorative ok
tu dis que tu as eu peur pour ta
sécurité et puis
qui est Elvis président qui était
présent au congrès le 16 janvier 2021
quand quand il y avait la cérémonie de
certification des présidents
interrompu la procédure il sait pas
poser à la certification
donc rompu avec Trump à ce moment-là
mais il n'y a pas été super critique du
de Trump par la suite là il est un peu
plus
puis bon tu le vois dans les médias les
gens lui demandent est-ce que tu appuies
Trump il se présente en 2024 c'est ce
contente de dire je pense que je pense
qu'il pourrait y avoir de meilleures
candidats
chorégraphié ça reste
bien problème il y a un problème pence
c'est que les partisans de Trump le
détestent évidemment c'est l'ennemi
parce que il y a l'arché trempe en cours
de route parmi les parmi les groupes qui
sont rendus au Capitole le 16 janvier
le monde grillé
la
présidente de la Chambre des
Représentants la démocrate il était visé
par certains individus qui étaient en
colère ce jour-là et qui qui voit en lui
une espèce de traître
dans les sondages j'ai à peu près je te
dirais 5-6% en ce moment bon troisième
puis de synthé c'est peut-être à 25 30%.
donc de Saint-Esprit
aux gens qui regardent qui écoutent le
podcast ou qui regardent ça sur Youtube
c'est que les primaires présidentielles
permettent un candidat de gagner la
nomination du parti en vue de l'élection
générale en vue de l'élection
présidentielle avec très peu de votes
c'est à l'élection générale peut-être
150 millions de personnes qui va
mais au primaire c'est beaucoup moins
que ça en 2016 là Trump est devenu
candidats républicain à la
présidentielle de 2016 en gagnant
seulement 15 millions de votes dans le
parti c'est pas beaucoup quasiment 10%
des votes donc là les gens disent pas
populaire le Trump il y a 65% des gens
qui laillent il y a juste 35 % des gens
qui l'appuient mais oui dans 35 % de
gens qui la puient au pays mais le
système des primaires fait que tu peux
devenir candidat avec 10% du vote à peu
près
même chose pour Biden il est devenu
candidat avec très peu de vote là si tu
compares le nombre de votes queues au
primaires au vote total à l'élection
générale donc c'est un système de
sélection des candidats qui est fait
comme ça
puis ça fait en sorte que les parties
parfois perdent le contrôle du processus
puis se retrouve obligé accepter une
nomination
appuyer par 15 millions d'électeurs mais
qui n'est pas nécessairement celle
que le parti voudrait mais comment ça
marche que votre poly primaire n'importe
qui peut voter ou quand non c'est
le système électoral américain est super
décentralisé il y a 50 États et les
règles électorales dépendent d'un état à
l'autre les lois électorales bon il y a
des lois fédérales qui qui régissent un
petit peu la manière de faire les
élections fédérales mais les États ont
encore beaucoup de marge de manœuvre
donc lors des primaires ça dépend des
États mais dans plusieurs États se sont
seulement les électeurs du parti qui
peuvent voter à la primaire du parti
mais dans d'autres États ce sont des
primaires ouvertes où là les
républicains sont par les primaires
républicaines peuvent voter évidemment
mais les autres électeurs aussi donc ça
dépend des États mais mais lors des
primaires se sont surtout les électeurs
du parti qui va et les électeurs les
plus motivés généralement ceux qui
suivent sa presse ceux qui a pu Un
candidat vraiment à fond le train c'est
pour ça que Trump il y a encore puissant
dans le parti
ces partisans ne l'ont pas beaucoup
lâcher en fait mais dans certains états
admettons je démocrate mais j'ai le
droit de voter aux primaire
républicaines puis que j'aille vraiment
trop je pourrais décider d'aller voter
pour un autre exaspirant exactement
exactement c'est permis dans certains
États mais dans la majorité des États ce
sont des primaires fermés qu'on appelle
c'est à dire juste les électeurs du
parti peuvent voter que juste ces
électeurs du parti peuvent voter à la
primaire de leur partie quand tu
t'enregistres comme électeur quand tu
t'inscris sur les listes électorales
dans ces états-là on te demande de
cocher une petite case pour nous dire tu
républicains et tu démocrates et tu
autre chose et tu es indépendant tout ça
donc si tu dis je suis républicain
Massy les primaires sont fermés tu
pourras seulement voter à la primaire de
ton parti la primaire républicain c'est
à dire je suis démocrate donc mais
encore là ça dépend des États mais ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que au primaire
républicaine ce sont surtout des
électeurs républicains qui votent et le
taux de participation est plus faible
qu'à l'élection générale souvent ce sont
les électeurs les plus motivés les plus
militants les plus à droite du côté
républicain et à gauche ben souvent du
côté démocrate souvent ce sont surtout
des électeurs plus motivés plus à gauche
souvent qui vote aux primaire ce qui
fait que Bernie Sanders parfois
on tire son tire son épingle du jeu lors
des primaires justement qu'en est-il des
longs on a parlé un peu des des
primaires républicaines mais qu'en
est-il de l'avenue du côté démocrate si
on parlait de Biden qui va pas qui va
sûrement se représenter mais que c'est
peut-être pas la volonté de tout le
monde dans le parti est-ce que comment
ça va fonctionner
décide de se présenter il pourrait quand
même y avoir des primaires démocrates
mais
il pourrait y avoir quand même des
primaires démocrates mais c'est pas
automatique le sens que si décide de se
représenter il y a pas nécessairement se
processus c'est-à-dire qu'il pourrait
être
le seul on a dit il y a quand même des
activités dans les états tout ça mais ce
sont pas des ce sont pas des primaires
aussi houleuses quand il y a plusieurs
candidats et tout ça donc si Bayonne
décide de se présenter il pourrait y
avoir des démocrates qui essaient de le
défier mais ça c'est super rare là c'est
pas très souvent dans l'histoire des
élections américaines en 1968 quand
Johnson était président garde du
vietnami était plus très populaire il y
a des démocrates qui disaient il faut le
défier lors des primaires parce qu'on
est dans le parti il y a beaucoup de
désaccords à son à son égard là Biden
les démocrates ont bien fait au médecin
de 2022
c'est plus difficile pour des démocrates
qui pensent qu'ils devraient s'en aller
de le défier en vue des primaires de
2024 si il décide de se présenter s'il
décide de quitter mais là oui il va y
avoir des primaires pour choisir le ou
la successeur
en vue de la générale de 2024 donc ce
que Biden a dit c'est que il y a les
réfléchir à ça durant le Thanksgiving
américain on est presque là vendredi
se décède parce que du côté républicain
c'est déjà lancé Trump c'est déjà lancé
et les primaires les primaires ont lieu
du début de l'année de l'élection
présidentielle jusqu'au mois de juin
donc ça commence officiellement en
janvier février 2024 mais avant c'est
les primaires c'est un une série de
votes dans les États américains où on
teste la viabilité des candidatures des
deux parties
donc ça commence en Iowa après son ou
même cher après ça on fait ça dans une
séquence de janvier au février jusqu'à
juin puis bon les candidats des deux
parties ramassent des points je vais
dire ça comme ça dans toute cette série
de votre là puis à la fin mais celui qui
a le mieux fait devienne candidat
simplifie beaucoup là mais devient
candidat à l'élection générale mais ça
commence oui pour revenir à ce que tu
disais bientôt officiellement début 2024
mais officieusement il faut que tu
commences bien avant ça faut que tu
ramasses l'argent faut que tu ramasses
des appuis il faut que tu formes une
équipe il faut que tu fasses les focus
group nécessaire pour savoir quelles
seront les enjeux d'avenir de quoi on va
parler comment on se met en scène
comment se présente ça dure deux ans ce
processus-là c'est pour ça que Trump a
déjà commencé il veut faire part aux
candidats qui pensent peut-être à se
lancer en disant moi je serai là donc si
tu veux te lancer penser à deux fois ou
reste chez toi si tu penses que je peux
te battre
donc c'est ça Biden doit décider
rapidement et selon ce que j'ai compris
il va y réfléchir durant Thanksgiving va
consulter ce qu'il appelle sa première
conseillère c'est à dire ça ça conjoint
Gilles Biden et
ce qu'on dit c'est qui pourrait s'y
décide de pas se lancer en 2024 pourrait
ou devrait l’annoncer assez rapidement
au début de l'année 2023
mais il y a deux il y a deux éléments
qui me portent à croire que c'est plus
difficile maintenant de pas se lancer
que de se lancer les résultats des
primaires
il y a bien fait la recette marche les
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
Biden est pas très populaire mais je me
suis amusé à décortiquer le le
vote de ceux qui ne l'aiment pas
beaucoup en fait c'est pas moi qui le
fait de les données sont disponibles et
j'ai regardé ça et parmi les électeurs
qui disent qui se disent plutôt
insatisfaits de Biden ça c'est 10 % de
l'électorat américain
la pluralité 49% ont voté démocrate au
mites et 45% voté républicain
habituellement les électeurs plutôt
insatisfaits du président vote pour
l'autre partie aux méthodes beaucoup
plus que pour le parti du président donc
c'est comme si
des lecteurs qui sont pas contents de
Biden mais qui disent mais il est quand
même pas suspect est-ce que c'est
dégueulasse
mais Biden et ses conseillers disent que
ce que ces électeurs-là aiment de Biden
c'est sa modération ce que je disais
tout à l'heure son calme
il crie pas
et on a envie de ça quand j'étais venu
la dernière fois j'avais dit le candidat
bouillon de poulet je sais pas si vous
voulez
puis c'est sûr que le monde ont eu puis
en tout cas pour certains ça semble être
déterminant
traiter un reporter de stupide sun of
the beach quand enregistrer la seule
chose qui a fait des fois il se met le
pied dans la bouche aussi
mais ça arrive moins souvent que c'est
pas à tout un jour et de la nuit donc ça
il y a ça et l'autre qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire ouais l'autre chose
pourquoi Biden c'est l'ensemble 2016
parce que Trump était là il l'a dit en
2016 il disait je reviens en politique
pour une raison je pense que Trump est
une menace à la démocratie et je pense
être en toute humilité celui qui peut le
battre parce que je détiens j'ai
derrière moi une coalition des lecteurs
démocrate que les autres n'ont pas je
suis capable de rassembler beaucoup
d'électeurs démocrate sous la tente
Biden alors que Bernie Sanders a plus de
difficulté à faire ça bon c'est vrai
Biden était peut-être le seul à pouvoir
faire ce qui a fait en 2016
au pays avec Michel Obama puis durant
les médecins
Biden fait campagne dans certains états
clés mais c'est Obama qui était là le
plus
à la semaine où on était là il était à
Detroit il y a une Pennsylvanie
puis il est encore super populaire
malheureusement pour ceux qui l'aiment
il peut pas se présenter pour un
troisième mandat c'est interdit mais il
est super populaire et Biden en profite
en quelque sorte parce qu'il est le
complice globama depuis
depuis longtemps et bon c'est ça donc
juste avant les méthodes de 2022 a donné
un discours encore une fois sur les
menaces à la démocratie américaine puis
il y a encore terminé la campagne de
2022 sur ce thème là donc si Trump se
présente en 2024
je trouverais ça bizarre qui se retire
alors que le combat reste entier mais
son âge
de 82 ans 86 afin de son mandat c'est
quoi le film
en espèces de
tout est possible
que tu exprimes
mais
c'est quoi le temps tu veux pas perdre
en 2024 des options il y en a plein du
côté démocrates il y a une relève là
c'est clair c'est ta camarade président
mais moins populaire que Biden au pays
mais juste avant d'aller dans juste par
rapport à
est-ce que sa décision est vraiment
juste la sienne ou bien presse faire un
peu mettre de la pression parti de là
faut que tu laisses ta place puis il
pourrait laisser sa place
c'est c'est sa décision c'est clair mais
mais c'est sûr que c'est conseillé se
prononcent
lui lui dise leur avis il y a des gens
dans le parti c'est sûr que je suis pas
dans secret des dieux je suis pas un
petit oiseau dans les pièces qui
comptent au moment où ces discussions là
ont lieu mais je peux très bien imaginer
que Barack Obama et Joe Biden on parlait
de ça parce qu'ils ont une relation de
confiance parce qu'au Basma était pas
sûr que Biden était le bon candidat en
2016 non plus il y avait c'était gardé
une petite gêne comme on dit
parce que pour des raisons que tu as
évoqué notamment
l'âge il y a de la relève tout ça
donc c'est sûr que il y a des démocrates
qui vont lui parler franchement Biden et
dire mais voici on va faire la liste des
cours et des comptes voici ben l'arche
c'est sûr
est-ce que est-ce que tu as envie de le
faire aussi ce que tu as envie de le
faire c'est super exigeant il y avait
des en 2016 je le fais pour sauver la
démocratie américaine
en 2016 il y a contribué maintenant
peut-être que ça job est faite et qu'il
peut
terminer sa vie un petit peu plus
sobrement calmement parce que bon oui
c'est c'est sûr que l'âge on peut pas
échapper à son âge depuis que j'ai
dépassé 30 ans il faut que je fasse une
sieste 80
mais mais oui c'est sûr qu'il y a des
gens qui disent puis l'autre à faire ça
aussi c'est important en 2016 Biden a
gagné
mais l'élection 2000 excuse-moi en 2020
bidon a gagné mais l'élection 2020 était
une élection particulière en pleine
pandémie au Biden n'a pas fait campagne
comme on fait campagne habituellement
c'est les républicains
il nous parle à travers à travers les
médias sociaux et sur zoom et tout ça
donc c'est une campagne un peu moins
exigeante que ce qu'on doit faire
habituellement où on doit visiter les
états clés après l'autre on doit serrer
des mains tout ça là 2024 ça risque
d'être à moins qu'il y a une autre
pandémie mais ça risque d'être une
campagne électorale normale normale
est-ce que Biden est capable d'en faire
une il y a des conseillers qui vont
discuter de ça avec lui
parce que c'est sûr que les républicains
vont critiquer ils vont dire et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il dort il fait une
sieste ce qui est mort
les républicains gèneront pas pour dire
et puis capable il y a des problèmes
cognitifs c'est ça
à propos du président des États-Unis
c'est quand même
mais ces médecins disent que non mais
les républicains disent que oui puis les
électeurs républicains ils ont pas tous
et toutes consulter les rapports
médicaux de Biden qui vont regarder
tocard
il comprend plus rien il dort dans les
réunions des fois il est complètement
perdu il se trompe il se dirige vers un
mur alors que la porte est par là
il y a des clips de Trump aussi
qui les démocrate les utilise et les
attaques personnelles vont être
nombreuses en 2024 mais
il faut voir c'est ça Biden doit
annoncer rapidement
pour l'instant on dit les républicains
sont un peu poignées avec trembler les
démocrates sont peut-être un peu
poignées
parce qu'il y a tout ça mais en même
temps il gagne mais même s'il annonce si
mettons qui annonce le dans un mois
maintenant il reste encore deux longues
années avant l'élection puis de 84
disons au début de l'année 2023
une présidentielle c'est
je pense c'est sûrement l'élection la
plus exigeante parmi celles qu'on parmi
celles qui se déroulent dans le monde ça
dure longtemps c'est c'est ça c'est les
attaques personnelles à n'en plus finir
tout ça en tout cas et tu dois gouverner
le pays tu dois être un président
excuse-moi
d'université des fois je suis fatigué
je suis en s’abattu
donc bref si finalement il se présente
pas c'est quoi les noms qui sont
pressenti à notre-dessus des
alternatives il y en a plein
il y en a plein je vais je vais aller
nommer on va faire une petite s je
voulais nommer dites-moi si vous les
connaissez
parce que
un des défis quand tu te lances à la
présidentielle c'est de faire connaître
c'est d'avoir une notoriété
un rayonnement national rapidement
d'être connu à l'échelle du pays
rapidement donc je connais juste et
aussi c'est la seule chose
et pourra se présenter au primaire
démocrate en tout cas donc et aussi fait
partie des candidatures
qu'on voit souvent dans les listes sinon
mais pas très populaire non puis on l'a
pas entendu parler dans le fond depuis
le début de la présidence Biden on a vu
un beau clip la journée de l'élection où
est-ce qu'elle disait où mais après ça
c'est comme moi évidemment je suis pas
ça c'est un niveau élite mais j'ai pas
entendu parler d'elle du tout non tu as
raison là on l'a pas vu beaucoup
c'est un peu particulier c'est un peu
étrange parce que quand byden a été élu
il y avait dit je veux je veux avec la
vice-présidente le genre de relation que
j'ai eu avec le président Obama quand
moi j'étais à Vesprit dans le voyage
souvent on le voyait souvent absolument
puis Obama lui a confié des dossiers
importants gestion des relations avec le
Congrès notamment parce que Biden avait
une longue expérience au Sénat
à l'international c'est Biden était
visible puis souvent dans les
apparitions publiques on les voyait les
deux
mais finalement pas fait ça avec
pourquoi
je sais pas est-ce que est-ce que les
conseillers de Biden avait peur qu'il se
fasse voler le chaud
par une vice-présidente un peu plus
d'énergie tout ça est-ce que c'est
simplement que Biden a un processus
décisionnel
un processus décisionnel qui fait en
sorte que la vice-présidente est souvent
écartée des discussions il lui avait
confié des dossiers importants aussi au
début de la présidence mais notamment le
dossier de la gestion
des mouvements migratoires à la
frontière américaine au mexicaine c'est
pas un dossier sur lequel on peut
briller c'est compliqué il y a eu Biden
c'est beaucoup fait critiquer
en raison de des mouvements migratoires
à la frontière l'arrivée de migrants non
documenté tout ça donc à malaris pouvait
pas vraiment plaire aux électeurs
électriques sur cet enjeu là puis
finalement là on le très peu vu et elle
n'est pas si populaire au pays son taux
d'approbation comme vice-présidente
et je pense moins élevé que le taux
d'approbation de Biden comme président
qui est à 42% donc ça donne une idée
puis durant les primaires démocrates de
2020 était pas à pas ça avait pas si
bien fait que ça non plus bien fait que
ça non plus donc mais c'est sûr que
décide de quitter elle va faire partie
elle devrait faire partie en principe
des candidats candidates en vue des
primaires démocrates sinon il y a le
secrétaire au transport puis bodygi qui
est un candidat en 2016 qui est un
candidats
de la ville de sainte-bern en Indiana
hyper charismatique télégénique articulé
mais qui avait bien fait quand même au
primaire de Minecraft en 2020 il y avait
bien fait il y avait bien fait lors des
premières des premiers votes en Iowa ou
new hamps le problème c'est qu'il est
pas très connu
aux quatre coins du pays et puis lors
des primaires dans le sud des États-Unis
ce qu'on a constaté c'est que lui est
bien d'autres n'avait pas beaucoup
d'appui auprès des électeurs
afro-américains là où Biden est très bon
parce qu'a été Elvis président Obama
j'avais expliqué ça la dernière fois
quand je suis venu au balado mais c'est
ça il faut une coalition pour gagner les
primaires des électeurs de ton parti et
body jet j'étais encore un petit peu
trop de novice à ce moment-là pas assez
connu l'oeil il est plus connu mais il
faut voir si c'est capable de
forger cette coalition d'électeurs sinon
parmi les autres mais il y a une
il y a une démocrate qui s'est fait
régler au poste de gouverneur au
Michigan qui est très populaire au
Michigan qui s'appelle Gretchen Wittmer
très très charismatique encore une fois
et tout ça mais elle a annoncé récemment
qu'elle n'avait pas l'ambition de se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
donc on verra elle peut changer d'idées
mais sinon greener je suis pas sûr c'est
pas un nom très très connu encore
c'est sinon Josh Shapiro je pense pas
que c'est un nom très très connu non
plus des gens qui regarderont le podcast
il vient juste de gagner une élection
importante au poste de gouverneur en
Pennsylvanie et une victoire nette alors
qu'en Pennsylvanie actuellement les
résultats peuvent être très serrés sont
généralement assez serrés lui a gagné ou
la main sans sa course au poste de
gouverneur il y a sinon Gavin nous
sommes gouverneur de la Californie
Bernie Sanders pourrait décider de se
présenter encore un autre inconnu ouais
je pense que oui
je pense que oui donc il y a le même âge
que Baden mais il y a une capacité
peut-être à ce niveau aussi que ça
paraît moins que
mais il y avait eu des ennuis de santé
plus importants que ceux de Biden durant
les dans les dernières années des ennuis
cartillac notamment mais le but Burny
c'est toujours de tirer le Parti
démocrate vers la gauche et aussi
pourraient jouer ce rôle là aussi et
aussi présente
si disons parce que je suis pas sûr que
je suis pas sûr que capable de réunir
beaucoup d'électeurs démocrates autour
de son projet parce qu'elle est très
très à gauche alors que beaucoup de
délecteurs modérés dans le parti quand
même mais elle va essayer si elle se
présente de gagner c'est sûr mais tirer
aussi le parti vers donc
il y a de la relève mais peut-être plus
pour 2028 que pour 2024 si c'est pour
2024 il faut que ça commence au plus
vite pour que ces gens-là puissent se
faire connaître rapidement
c'est ça c'est un défi ça était connu
aussi en 2020 ça aide
des candidats
c'est des personnes qui sont capables
d'un peu jouer la même game que Trump un
peu de leur tenir j'ai l'impression que
quelqu'un de trop modérée
dans un débat comme impossible de battre
avec Donald Trump si tu utilises pas un
peu des méthodes un petit peu plus du
coup ouais c'est ça ils sont ils sont
très très bons pour ça
il est capable il brasse la cage comme
on dit durant les primaires démocrates
il y avait brassé
Clinton en 2016 avait forcé Clinton à se
remettre un petit peu en question sur le
commerce le libre-échange
les emplois dans le Midwest américain
c'est beau la mondialisation mais ça a
mené à des pertes d'emploi importantes
dans mes doigts Clinton nous en parlait
pas assez le prix des médicaments tout
ça
puis au fond Burny a donné une voix aux
électeurs de la classe ouvrière si on
utilise des termes marxistes les gens
les moins fortunés et puis le Parti
démocrate les avait oublié un peu oublié
durant Obama
puis Clinton allait un petit peu dans le
même sens qu'au Basma avec son programme
en 2016
est arrivé en 2020 avec un programme
beaucoup plus à gauche que ce qu'il
aurait fait habituellement
ça ça je pense que je pense que ce
message-là de Bunny ce message dès aussi
aussi sur les inégalités économiques sur
la dette étudiante sur
sur l'accès à la santé ça ça reste très
très important des emplois américains
qui redonner de bons emplois aux
Américains Trump le 10 en 2016 mais
Burny aussi le disait en 2016 Élodie
encore ça c'est c'est un message qui
peigne encore dans le parti démocrate et
notamment dans une région clé de
l'élection présidentielle qui est celle
qu'on a qu'on a visité avant limiteur je
le mets d'ouest des Grands Lacs en
Pennsylvanie il y a un gars qui a gagné
la sénatoriale qui s'appelle John
Federman je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler
un peu à la Burnie Sanders très classe
ouvrière colle bleue on va vous redonner
de bons emplois c'est il se promène avec
un Audi les fait campagne avec un Audi
très très au rat des pancrées qui a été
maire de Brad up une petite municipalité
en banlieue de Pitts on est allé là tu
vois c'est des communautés là
sur le derrière là l'embauche des
maisons abandonnées des usines des
affectées des usines pratiquement
fermées des assiéries ou outils il y
avait de bons emplois il y a 30 40 ans
et où Ben il se passe plus grand chose
c'est très polluant tout ça
et Trump a gagné en 2016 notamment en
disant à des gens comme des gens qui
habitent ces communautés on va penser à
vous on va vous redonner de bonnes job
puis la Chine on était carré de se faire
avaler des emplois par nos compétiteurs
et et les démocrates tiennent aussi ce
discours là par le biais de candidats
comme Bunny et aussi dans une certaine
mesure également mais John Federman qui
a gagné la scène internationale en
Pennsylvanie si les gens qui regardent
le podcast veulent voir
une des lignes de fracture dans le parti
démocrate en ce moment aller voir qui
est John Federman et comparer là par
exemple Hillary Clinton dans le temps
vous allez voir que c'est pas ils sont
tous les deux démocrate mais ils ont
rien ils ont pratiquement rien en commun
et
en fait fait la synthèse entre les deux
c'est ça qui est particulier parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui peigne auprès des de
la classe ouvrière des cols bleus des
travailleurs en difficulté parce que
il y a ce parcours là personnel il vient
d'une famille
qui est plutôt de cette classe sociale
qui a été sénateur mais pendant toute sa
carrière de sénateur il y a habité
encore des quartiers
où il y a des Américains un peu dans
dans cette situation qui le côtoyait au
quotidien puis serait la main tout le
monde puis et puis il a toujours tenu
cette espèce de discours là on doit
aider les travailleurs et tout ça même
s'il était le vice-président dobama même
si il est chiami Tommy avec Hillary
Clinton il y a un peu plus cette
sensibilité là mais en même temps hyper
pas les démocrates plus modérés plus et
financièrement qui disent
ben il faut quand même s'intéresser à
des questions
mais mais pour résumer du côté
démocrates il y a une belle relève mais
il va falloir que ça commence bien tôt
parce que ce sont pas des gens
extrêmement connus encore
c'est ça pour 2028 par contre Biden fait
deux mandats puis là évidemment les gens
que je vous ai nommés auront plus
d'expérience sur ce qu'on fait connaître
et tout ça mais pour 2024 c'est ça
c'est drôle ce que j'avais lu l'idée que
probablement
un peu de des États-Unis
à l'international c'est surtout nous on
a parlé avec Julien qui est venu ici on
a parlé de Julien Touré qui est venu
parler de la guerre en Ukraine puis
dernièrement il y a eu comme des
missiles tombées en Pologne
quelle est la posture américaine en ce
moment sur la guerre en Ukraine un petit
week-end de où est-ce qu'on est rendu a
fait un petit bout qu'on en a parlé bon
évidemment les il y a une aide
financière très très impassible massive
de loin les États-Unis c'est de loin
ceux qui aident le plus l'Ukraine dans
la situation absolument une aide massive
une aide massive une aide militaire une
aide humanitaire et durant les meetum il
y a eu un débat sur cette politique là
on a très peu parlé de politique
étrangère mais l'Ukraine évidemment a
retenu l'attention pour des raisons
évidentes
au sein du parti républicain il y a des
candidats plus proche de Trump qui
estiment qu'on devrait pas poursuivre sa
taille militaire à l'Ukraine ils sont
plus proches de la Russie d'ailleurs si
vous allez voir le compte le compte
prout
de Trump sur ce média ça sur lui il est
dans cet univers là vous voyez que Trump
évidemment critique beaucoup la
politique de Biden l'aide à l'Ukraine et
tout ça il est plus proche de la de la
Russie il y a des républicains qui sont
un peu dans cette dans cet état d'esprit
là durant les méthodes c'est
républicains qui sont minoritaires au
sein du parti je pense qu'il faut dire
ça on dit il faudrait peut-être réduire
ou couper cette aide là à un moment
donné du côté démocrate c'est assez
particulier tu as
le concert demandé au Congrès des votes
sur des budgets parce que je le disais
tantôt c'est le Congrès qui adopte les
budget des votes sur des budgets
importants pour continuer à aider
l'Ukraine je pense pas qu'à court terme
le Congrès va remettre ça en question je
pense qu'il va y avoir des petits débats
il va y avoir certains républicains qui
diront c'est assez certain démocrates
qui diront stacées mais Biden a quand
même les votes nécessaires au sein des
deux chambres du Congrès pour poursuivre
cette politique là et si tu regardes
l'opinion publique américaine tu
constates qu'une grande majorité
d'Américains qui estiment que c'est la
bonne chose à faire en ce moment pour
suivre l'aide à l'Ukraine et je voyais
un sondage qui disait qu'il y a 60% des
Américains américaines qui pensent qu'on
devrait que les États-Unis devraient
aider l'Ukraine peu importe jusqu'à la
fin du conflit autant
tentez aussi longtemps que ce sera
nécessaire donc c'est une politique qui
reste populaire au pays Biden veut
continuer la majorité des deux chambres
du Congrès veut continuer aussi donc
l'aide à l'Ukraine dépendra de
l'évolution du conflit là-bas et pour
l'instant bon je suis pas expert de
l'Ukraine je suis pas expert de la
Russie mais j'en discutais avec un
collègue la semaine passée qui suit
beaucoup le dossier qui expert de la
Russie qui disait honnêtement je ne sais
pas comment ça va se terminer je ne vois
pas quand ça va se terminer je ne sais
pas quand et je ne sais pas quand ça va
se terminer
est-ce que ton ami est inquiète de
comment ça peut dégénérer peut-être ce
conflit là ouais ouais
on fait le collègue en question je vais
le nommer parce que je vais rendre à 16h
ce qu'on doit à 16h c'est Yann Brot du
Collège militaire royal de Saint-Jean
parce que je suis allé donner une
conférence sur les méthodes là-bas puis
on a parlé de et il est expert de la
Russie expert de la politique interne
russe
et bon évidemment il y a beaucoup de
propagande en ce moment on sait pas tout
à fait ce qui se passe dans l'entourage
de Poutine et dans la tête de Poutine
surtout mais ce qui me disait c'est j'en
ai c'est pas du tout où ça s'en va c'est
pas un je ne sais pas
négatif c'est juste un aucune idée non
puis il me parlait un petit peu de la
relève qu'elle serait la relève ses
Poutine meurent ces Poutine kit et
honnêtement ça reste inquiétant mais
disait-il et assez imprévisible
on sait pas trop on connaît pas tout à
fait les intentions de Poutine on sait
pas pourquoi on le sait un peu pourquoi
Poutine s'obstine à poursuivre la guerre
là-bas c'est une question de fierté
nationale c'est un enjeu historique pour
pour bien des Russes qui estiment que ce
territoire fait partie de l'image
beaucoup oui avec le territoire m'a fait
partie de du grand ensemble qui existait
avant et qui était sous qui était sous
emprise russe c'est que ça nous
appartient puis il y a des communautés
là-bas
culturel qui qui nous ressemble et qui
devrait faire partie de de notre grand
ensemble territorial et tout ça
mais ce qui ce qui est beaucoup
d'observateurs au fond c'est c'est
l'impréparation
russe
la surestimation des capacités russes à
gagner cette guerre là
les pertes russes en sol ukrainien bon
évidemment il y a un appui de la part
des Américains il y a qui fait que
l'Ukraine peut résister et d'autres
alliés qui fait que l'Ukraine peut
résister que la guerre conventionnelle
tourne souvent à l'avantage des
Ukrainiens qui sont très déterminés
aussi sur le terrain on le vit aussi
c'est devenu une question de fierté
nationale aussi pour bien des biens des
combattants Ukrainiens mais les pertes
russes incroyables il y a des sites
internet où on
ou en répertorie
les pertes russes de soldats les pertes
de matériel les pertes d'équipements
militaires et tout ça je suis pas un
expert de ça mais et je pourrais je me
souviens pas du site en question qu'on
consulte à la chair à eux d'endurance
j'ai oublié le nom du site mais c'est
incroyable les perturus en solurénées
alors qu'on dit que la Russie est une
superpuissance et elle elle en est une
mais on a on a surestimé les capacités
de son a pas bien préparé ça et il y a
toutes sortes d'histoires de soldats
russes qui sont déployés sur le terrain
qui sont totalement désorientés et qui
se font presque tuer dès leur arrivée
dans des combats où on n'a pas trop
prévu ce qu'on allait faire c'est fou
versus
ukrainiennes il y a une proportion une
grande proportion
si on considère que la Russie est une
superpuissance et que l'Ukraine n'en est
pas une
c'est assez étonnant de comparer les
pertes des deux pays dans cette
guerre-là pour l'instant donc mais pour
en revenir à au débat aux États-Unis
là-dessus je pense pas parce que avant
l'élection on disait ça se peut qu'il y
a une remise en question de ça au
Congrès après les méthodes mais je ne
vois pas cette remise en question pour
l'instant et d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé en Pologne l'instant
vous avez vu dans les médias on disait
les médias sont un peu emballés la
Russie commence à bombarder les pays
difficiles russes frappe la Pologne les
pays membres de l'OTAN devront peut-être
considérer l'idée de riposter parce que
un membre de l'OTAN est attaqué et tout
ça la collectivité atteignante doit
assurer la défense de l'État qui a été
attaqué et puis on craignait presque la
troisième bière mondiale mais
et c'est ça cet incident là mais surtout
la série de frappes que précédé cet
incident rappelle aux républicains et
aux démocrates que c'est loin d'être
terminé et que ça allait d'Américains
dans cette guerre là ce sera pas celui
qu'on soit même si il y a des
républicains qui sont plus pour eux tout
ça donc pour l'instant pas de remise en
question de cette politique
c'est ça qui est drôle c'est que
tout à l'heure je vous disais la société
américaine et les deux parties sont
extrêmement divisés sur beaucoup de
questions
l'environnement la santé tout ça les
questions politiques intérieures on voit
qu'il y a des divisions très très
importantes mais en politique étrangère
il y a plus de consensus sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine il y a plus de consensus entre
les républicains et les démocrates sur
la politique américaine à l'égard de la
Chine les républicains et les démocrates
dit souvent la même chose depuis Trump
en fait Trump a été
a été un tournant
à ce titre parce que mon cyan guerre
commerciale contre la Chine
est une superpuissance qui veut
renverser l'équilibre des puissances
internationales à son avantage il faut
pas
on peut collaborer avec la chaîne mais
il faut pas se faire des lusions c'est
un pays qui va être la première super
puissance un jour c'est nous c'est nous
qui allons à payer le prix bon la Chine
vole la propriété intellectuelle des
entreprises américaines vous connaissez
le dire au Québec
récemment mais aux États-Unis c'est très
fréquent et Trump a été le premier
président en parler autant que ça
commercial ils sont déloyaux à notre
égard ils manipulent leur devise pour
exporter davantage en sols américains
donc tout ça mais la Chine est la Chine
est un ennemi mais ce qui est quand même
curieux parce que
en même temps Poutine Trump et
quand même amical avec la Russie qui est
un allié de la Chine finalement
oui ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
comprendre de Trump c'est que
c'est souvent les gens disaient c'est
pas c'est pas un président qui a
une idéologie particulière c'est
politique sont des politiques à la carte
des fois il y a pas toujours de logique
dans son programme il y a des
contradictions comme celle-là
alors que du côté démocrate ben oui
c'est vrai
la Chine les démocrates voient la Chine
comme un peut-être pas comme un ennemi
je pense pas qu'on emploie toujours ce
terme-là mais très certainement comme un
compétiteur inquiétant et les démocrates
vont aussi la Russie comme un
compétiteur inquiétant Trump était moins
critique de la Russie pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait une certaine
admiration pour ce qui aime le gars
carrément ça et là vous savez il y a des
enquêtes à propos de Trump en ce moment
sur son passé financier bon il y a une
décision de la Cour suprême
récente qui autorise les démocrates de
la Chambre des représentants à avoir
accès aux rapports fiscaux de Trump pour
les dernières années et Trump voulait
pas que ce soit public on va savoir
pourquoi mais peut-être qu'a-t-il à
titre d'homme d'affaires il a eu il a eu
des liens
importants avec des hommes d'affaires
russes des entreprises russes des des
gens importants en Russie qui comme
président
l'empêchait d'être trop critique de la
Russie
l'empêchait d'être trop dur à l'égard de
la Russie parce que sa famille et lui
avait encore des intérêts personnels
l'espèce de gros conflit d'intérêt
possible en Russie entre les intérêts de
l'homme d'affaires et les intérêts du
président qui est pas top comme
président à l'égard de la Russie parce
qu'il veut pas que sa famille perd de
trop si jamais la Russie se forge contre
lui à titre de président
me semble facile à trouver c'est à
retracer là mettons le genre tu es deux
jours de retard ça a Revenu Québec sur
soit 4 lettres puis deux email genre je
comprends pas pourquoi le président des
États-Unis est pas c'est pas facile
d'avoir ces relevés fiscaux puis de
regarder les liens de ces business là je
comprends pas pourquoi ça se peut pas se
faire en 24 heures mais Trump c'est
battu en cours pour gagner du temps donc
ce qui le dit c'est
souvent ce qu'il a dit c'est j'ai le à
titre de président je devrais avoir des
privilèges que les autres Américains
n'ont pas donc le privilège exécutif
exécutif souvent durant sa présidence il
s'est battu
il s'est battu en cours il s'est battu
avec le Congrès quand le congrès de
demander des documents avoir accès à des
documents tout ça il s'est battu en
disant ben j'ai je devrais avoir le
privilège de de ne pas vous les remettre
ces documents là et là ce qu'il dit
c'est que à titre d'ancien président il
devrait avoir le même privilège puis un
gros débat aux États-Unis là-dessus mais
sur le privilège exécutif premièrement
puis sur le privilège des anciens
présidents habituellement à titre
d'anciens présidents tu devrais
redevenir un américain comme les autres
c'est ce que certains jugent en ce
moment disent donc monsieur Trump c'est
bien dommage mais vous n'êtes plus
président et là d'ailleurs c'est la Cour
suprême qui vient de rendre cette
décision là et vous êtes un ancien
président et les démocrates ont
maintenant le droit pour faire la
lumière sur sur ce que vous avez fait
pendant que vous étiez président et
avant d'être président faire la lumière
là-dessus les démocrates ont le droit
d'avoir accès à ces documents là mais ce
sont des batailles juridiques et souvent
[Musique]
pour des raisons personnelles et tout ça
que Trump aurait utilisé les avoir et
les bilans financiers de cette
organisation pour payer lui moins
d'impôts sur le plan personnel donc
c'est enquête là ça fait longtemps
qu'elle dure mais ça prend du temps
parce que Trump
Trump utilise toujours toutes sortes de
manigances pour ralentir le processus
judiciaire mais lorsqu'on a appris c'est
que le procès sur cette question là va
commencer officiellement je pense qu'ils
ont dit octobre 2023
à un moment où Trump va être en campagne
électorale donc ça reste imprévisible
parce que
non c'est pas s'il va être s'il va être
accusé
donc ça reste imprévisible pour cette
raison là
mais
mais c'est ça sur la Russie moi je
l'expliquerai comme ça notamment
l'espèce de
l'espèce de tendresse de Trump à l'égard
de Monsieur Poutine de la Russie puis
parlant de Trump c'est démêler avec la
justice il y avait pas une enquête
justement sur l'assaut Capitole puis tu
es de c'est quoi ça parle de
responsabilités là dedans ça pourrait
être sûr de venir quelque chose qui est
l'incrémine puis qui fait qui en sorte
qui pourrait par exemple se représenter
ouais
ce qui a eu sur le 6 janvier 2021
en fait ce qu'il y a eu c'est au congrès
à la Chambre des représentants des
démocrates et des républicains ont créé
une commission d'enquête sur le sur les
attaques du 6 janvier 2021 donc une
commission d'enquête qui a qui a
recueilli des informations sur ce qui
s'était passé qui a entendu des
témoignages de conseiller de Trump de
membres de son entourage et tout ça donc
on a documenté l'affaire et une des
conclusions de la commission c'est dire
que Trump est le principal responsable
ou en tout cas un des principaux
responsables de ce qui s'est passé le 6
janvier 2021
donc
le département de la justice américaine
se penche également sur cette affaire
se penche également sur une autre
affaire qui est celle
qui concerne les documents secrets que
Trump a ramené chez lui après avoir
quitté la Maison Blanche les fameux
documents qui avaient Amara Lago à sa
résidence des documents qui devraient
pas être là en principe parce qu'il y a
des lois fédérales américaines qui
disent qu'une fois que tu quittes la
Maison Blanche il y a beaucoup de
documents qui deviennent en fait la
propriété du gouvernement fédéral qui
doivent aller dans les archives surtout
les documents secrets
on nous a fait tellement
de golf puis en fait Trump Trump est
toujours fier de ce qui a accomplit tout
ça puis ce qu'on comprend c'est c'est
qu'il reçoit des gens morts à Lago qui
est fier de leur montrer des documents
[Rires]
management disparu mais c'est il peut ce
sont des documents qui peuvent révéler
l'identité d'agent secret américain qui
peuvent se retrouver entre les mains
d'ennemis des États-Unis qui savent que
Joe s'expack telle adresse à Columbus en
hawaiio est un agent de la CIA on va
aller chercher chez lui tu sais donc
il y a 7 ans quête-là du département de
la justice il y a l'enquête de l'État de
New York sur les fraudes fiscales il y a
il y a toutes sortes d'affaires comme ça
qui font en sorte que je sais que dans
certaines lois fédérales on mentionne le
fait que
que Trump
qu'on fait on pourrait on pourrait
déterminer que Trump ne peut plus être
éligible à
occuper la fonction ultime au sein de la
Maison Blanche mais je sais pas si on va
aller jusque-là je sais pas si on va
aller jusque-là parce que le problème
avec ça
c'est que ça donne encore plus
l'occasion aux partisans de Trump de
dire qu'il est une victime qu'un
dépistage qui est contre lui depuis le
début et que ces gestes là sont
politiques sont politiques et ne sont
pas impartiaux parce que le département
de la Justice au fond il a à sa tête un
démocrate au fond Mary Garland qui a été
nommé par le président Biden Mary Garlin
fait sa job de façon impartiale il
essaie de la faire de façon impartiale
mais s'il y a des accusations très très
strictes à l'égard de Trump et tout ça
c'est sûr et certain que ceux qui
suivent Trump vont dire ben vous voyez
c'est encore la preuve que le
gouvernement contre lui et Trump veut
jouer cette carte là
donc je pense que il pourrait y avoir
des conséquences
notamment l'enquête dans l'État de New
York pourrait exiger que Trump et sa
famille rambourse je me souviens plus de
la du montant mais je pensais 250
millions de dollars endommage et intérêt
pour pour les irrégularités qu'on a
trouvé dans les documents qu'on a
épluchés donc il pourrait y avoir des
conséquences comme ça mais de
d'empêcher Trump de tenter sa chance en
nouveau à nouveau en vue de 2024
ça peut se retourner contre
c'est ça
se présenter est-ce que
il y a toutes sortes d'inconnues aussi
est-ce qu'il respecte le est-ce qu'il
respecte le jugement est-ce qu'il va en
appel est-ce qu'il continue à se battre
donc au fond ceux et celles qui mène ses
enquêtes là soit
que le tribunal de l'opinion publique
finisse par tirer ses conclusions
je pense que c'est ça le souhait
d'Amérique Garland c'est ça le souhait
de
c'est quand même un moment donné
il ne soit plus éligible parce que plus
personne qui l'a pluie s'il soit
tellement à terre que on a même plus
besoin de l'empêcher de se présenter il
y a plus personne qui veut de lui je
pense que c'est ça le scénario idéal
pour
pour le département de la justice
notamment puis
je pense que c'est ça mais pour
l'instant pour l'instant il y a encore
80% des électeurs républicains qui
aiment dans notre choix
[Rires]
2024 c'est drôle il y a des collègues au
département Sciences politiques à l'UQAM
qui m'a écrit un courriel puis on dit
puis si tu en parles je suis fatigué
déjà
ça devient épuisant au contraire en fait
j'ai vu sur Instagram Valérie Baudouin
qu'on a reçu ou podcast
j'ai de la job pour les prochaines
années
non mais c'est fascinant en même temps
c'est sûr ça va être intéressant
mais moi je vous jure le 16 janvier 2021
je trouvais plus ça drôle
bizarre coloré
des conséquences comme ça c'est plus
diversification
on n'est pas capable de terminer
d'aller au bout de la procédure
d'une élection présidentielle
tu as une société qui glisse vers un
autre genre de régime politique
on va terminer bientôt mais c'est une
impression que les médias
ont eu leur leçon de comment traiter de
Trump comment couvrir Trump j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont créé un monstre
en quelque sorte un couvrant tellement
toutes ces phrases que ça lui fait juste
donner plus de visibilité est-ce qu'on
va joindre si ça représente 2024 comment
qu'on le représente je pense que je
pense qu'on le voit déjà puis un exemple
concret qui illustre ça contre un pas
annoncé
qui se lançait officiellement à la
présidentielle de 2024 le journal
un gars je me rappelle plus c'est quel
journal de New yorkout qui a dit moi je
vois plus traiter Trump
sur la première page journal c'était
marqué
Floride domaine de side to genre de se
présenter comme président
en plus c'était stupide la page
couverture je me rappelle c'est déjà un
affaire un peu au hasard là du coup il y
avait rien à voir c'est comme fleuri
domaine des claires
en votre journal c'est incroyable bonne
journée et puis page 24
[Rires]
vous vous irez voir le texte c'est comme
c'est un entre filet c'est un petit
texte Benco puis tu vois clairement que
le journal se fout de la gueule ça
à faire qui lui fait mal franchement
donc on a vu ça mais aussi sur les
réseaux de télévision
il y a beaucoup de réseaux qui ont qui
ont pas présenté le discours ou qui ont
décidé en fait d'interrompre la
couverture du disco assez rapidement
c'est pour ne pas lui donner cette
visibilité là qui l'a clairement aidé en
2016 ça c'est chiffré en passant là ça
vaut une tonne d'argent cette visibilité
gratuite ça a été chiffrée on sait ce
que ça coûte une publicité de 30
secondes sur les ondes de CNN donc ça a
été chiffré c'est comparativement
Clinton en 2016 il y a beaucoup profité
de ça donc les médias ont peut-être
appris mais on verra si ça dure parce
que c'est un moment donné on aura si si
l'île candidat on n'aura pas le choix de
le montrer c'est il va avoir des débats
il va y avoir des débats présidentiels
il va y avoir
puis bon dans l'intérêt public à un
moment donné tu dois couvrir un certain
nombre de choses il a déclaré telle
chose il annonce telle à faire mais déjà
en 2020
les médias avaient fait les choses
différemment
avait fait les choses différemment on
verra ça en 2020 avant de faire les
choses différemment il y avait pas eu
d'insurrections
sinon ce les médias font beaucoup c'est
le fond depuis 30 et dans le décor c'est
ce qu'on appelle du FAC checking
mais ça a vraiment ses limites ça parce
que les gens qui sont déjà convaincus
que Trump
que les médias veulent le faire mal
pareil puis racontent des sottises
quand quelque chose est pas factuel puis
c'est ce que tu fais
tu vas quand même te faire dire que qui
était politisé parce que tu prends
position quand tu dis que
[Musique]
sont très contents du travail que tu
fais mais ceux qui pensent que tu es
moins que rien tu t'écouteront pas de
toute façon l'autre l'autre l'autre
affaire qui serait intéressant à
surveiller c'est Twitter ouais c'est ça
parce que là il a une masque fait ce
qu'il fait sur Twitter vous avez vu pour
la liberté d'expression à outrance et
ben je sais pas si vous êtes sur Twitter
mais le paysage a déjà
recommencé à changer a commencé à
changer
il y a des Alexis cossettes Trudel au
Québec sont de retour sur Twitter il y a
il y a cet univers conservateur et
d'extrême droite qui revient lentement
mais sûrement trempé de retour sur
Twitter a dit qu'il n'utiliserait pas
son compte Twitter on va avoir
je pense qu'il y a des lycées auprès de
truth ok
donc je pense je connais pas les détails
de l'entendre mais je pense qu'il je
pense que pendant les 6 premières heures
suivant une publication il ne peut pas
diffuser ça ailleurs ou quelque chose
comme ça
mais quand même puis est-ce que Twitter
on verra ce que Twitter est en perdition
mais c'est ça donc c'est un peu des deux
il y a certains médias qui semblent
avoir appris ils veulent faire les
choses autrement couvrir quand c'est
obligatoire nécessaire mais pas tout
couvrir non plus mais il y a d'autres
milieux ou
c'est voilà les mensonges les théories
du complot
seront plus présente que ce qu'on avait
en 2020 par exemple
ou après 2020 merci beaucoup
élections
à toi